by the way if you want to celebrate the
return of full power s candor and
support this channel at the same time
you can check out our merch store anime
out Broadcom including this s Canora
praise the sun shirt a stellar best
seller and also the Eskin or all hailed
the one shirt Eskin or in the one form
both designs are originals created by
Cuusoo midi exclusively for anime on
Broadcom what is up everybody its Anna
Mak here for anime uproar and today I
will be once again talking about the
latest twists and turns in the epic
story of the seven deadly sins including
the long-awaited return of the Sun
praiser in chief full power s kannur I
mentioned in the previous few videos
that I'm convinced that all this talk
about Eskin or dying was just another
troll by the Creator knockabout Suzuki
because there is no way that the master
of the Sun s Kannur was going to die at
least not before he finally make sweet
sweet love to Merlin and as it turns out
s Kannur is not only alive and well but
he is now back in full form and ready to
take on the demon king I can't wait to
get into all these juicy plot twists if
you enjoyed the seven deadly sins
content on this channel you can leave a
like to let me know and if you're new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell you can
also follow us on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar for all the latest 7
that these sins updates and as usual
this video will contain manga spoilers
we're gonna be talking about the latest
developments in the seven deadly sins
stories so please proceed with caution
you have been warned chapter 317 starts
off with an injured esken or still
bravely fighting against the spawn of
the Endura even though he is clearly no
match for the monster in his sunshine
less for Gil Thunder tries to help s
Connor but it's no use the monster is
just too strong that said a scanner
shows incredible bravery and
determination by continuing to fight
despite being severely injured when the
holy Knights wonder how a scanner can
still be fighting when he is injured
worse than they are and they are lying
helplessly on the ground a scanner tells
them that in the
he was on the receiving end of
melioidosis blows and even though he was
then in his daytime form the pain was so
bad he thought he would die compared to
the attacks Emilio dhis this current
pain is like an insect bite I thought
that it was interesting that s Kannur
brought up his fight against Mellie Otis
at this point in time first of all it
reminds us of how powerful the Otis
truly is and what it really means to be
on the level of the demon king and at
the same time it reminds us that s
Kannur is indeed human sure he had
sunshine and this made him incredibly
strong but he was never immortal and he
was never a member of an extremely
powerful magical species so even when he
was using sunshine he still had to deal
with and overcome intense pain and
struggle it's easy to miss this because
of how supremely confident s Connor
always is in his daytime form so I
thought that it was really cool for
escarole to bring this up and remind us
that despite the brave and cocky front
that he puts up s Kannur is and always
was just a human who was blessed but
also cursed with an incredible power s
Kannur tells Gill thunder Houser angry
amore that he will continue to fight to
be their shield and that they have to
use this time to get away even if they
have to crawl on their hands and knees
to do it but unfortunately for s Kannur
it doesn't take long for the Endura
spawn to completely overwhelm him and he
loses both of his arms during the battle
we then witness a brief moment where s
Cano feels ashamed that he is so weak
compared to the other sins and he thinks
that if they saw how pathetic he was in
this moment they would definitely laugh
at him however that moment of doubt
lasts only for a short period of time
because s Canora soon realizes that no
that is not true the other sins see him
as one of their own and they respect and
appreciate him no matter what form he is
in daytime or nighttime s canora's
comforted by this thought and it makes
him even more determined to see this
final battle through to the end as he is
about to be killed by the Endura spawn s
kannur says that he wants to be with the
sins to the very end even if only in
spirit because he is the seven deadly
sins lion sin of pride s Kannur this was
such a powerful and emotion
moment and it emphasizes yet again the
fascinating duality of ask a Norse
character we all know the memes about
how o-p-s Kannur is praise the Sun and
all that good stuff and we know his
famous prideful quotes like who decided
that and in this realm kings such as
yourself are as numerous as grains of
sand but I am no such thing I am unlike
any other existence in the world the
lion sin of pride ESCA nor we love how
cocky and overpowered Eska nor is in his
daytime form but we also know that
beyond that larger-than-life persona
Eska nor is also a deeply frail and
insecure person like so many of us
humans the fact that s can or has flaws
and doubts like everybody else is very
clear when he is in his nighttime form
but the truth is that even during the
day when s kannur is at his strongest
and most confident he still has inner
doubts and flaws he is still shown
wondering whether merlin will ever feel
about him the way he feels about her he
gets jealous and Sola in the fact that
SK are in this current form without
sunshine was able to overcome all of his
many fears and doubts in order to stand
bravely against the Endura spawn until
the very end is beautiful and truly
inspirational to all of us mere humans
who don't have the power of sunshine but
of course this is the seven deadly sins
and so naturally our boy s Kannur isn't
really going to die instead just as he
is about to be eaten by the monster
miles suddenly shows up destroys the
monster and miraculously heals s Kannur
mile has answered ask Norse prayers and
he has come to his aid
mile says that he will happily protect
this land and the innocent people here
from any approaching danger including
the Endora spawn but he says that he
can't go and fight the demon king
despite being the strongest of the four
Archangels mile appears to be afraid of
the demon king and he says that he
simply cannot stand against him this
just emphasizes yet again how strong the
demon king and malleolus are at this
point they're on a totally different
level and even my L doesn't think that
he can make a difference in a fight
against the demon king however s Connor
explains that he did not call mile to
fight the demon
he called miles so that he could land
esken are the power of sunshine once
again and then s Canora will do the
fighting mile warns s Kannur that his
body is already at its limit from all
the strain that sunshine has put on it
and if he tries to use it again he may
be able to use it in one more fight but
after that he will without a doubt
perish essentially mile warns that s
Connor will be giving up his life if he
decides to take on the power of sunshine
once again
but as Kannur replies that he is aware
of the risks and he doesn't mind he
doesn't see it as throwing his life away
he sees it as risking his life for the
sake of his best friends since the other
sins are willing to put their lives on
the line to rescue others s can or is
willing to do the same for them Miele
agrees to give sunshine back to s Canora
and tells him that there's still time
before noon as sunshine returns to s
Canora we immediately see them growing
immensely in size and stature and the
next chapter is called chaotic battle
which implies that we are going to
witness a massive showdown and that s
can or will likely be involved mile
mentioning that it's not yet noon also
implies that s Canora will be able to
attain his the one form during the big
chaotic battle that is coming up so that
will be extremely interesting to see
although I was really hoping that we
would get to see my L in the one mode
sometime in the future
still I think we've all been waiting for
a long time to see s Kannur at full
power and in action once again so I'm
excited to see what's to come but we
have to remember this although s Connor
was just saved by my L miles words about
s Connors body being at its limit
indicate that s Connors life is still in
danger he is about to use the power of
sunshine in order to fight in this epic
showdown but this fight may be too much
for his body to handle and he could die
because of it this chapter definitely
leaves us on the edge of our seats and
I'm sure that we are all wondering how
much s control will be able to handle
and what his ultimate fate will be at
the end I've said it before and I'll say
it again
I don't think that s Connor will die
even if his body is badly damaged during
this next battle I believe that Merlin
Elizabeth or someone else will find a
way to heal him and he
stay alive as a massive Merlin and esken
or shipper I am waiting for them to end
up together in the end and I will not
let anyone convince me that a different
ending is possible in fact I'm working
on a video right now about what would
happen if Merlin and esken or had a baby
and what types of powers this child
could potentially have so if you don't
want to miss that video be sure to
subscribe and click that notification
bell if you haven't already the only way
to get notifications on YouTube now is
to make sure that you have enabled all
notifications for this channel so please
do that right now
the s Kannur and merlin baby video will
feature drawings of the child and its
powers by pro manga artist Cuusoo Murray
so definitely be on the lookout for that
by the way if you want to celebrate the
return of full power s kannur and
support this channel at the same time
you can check out our merch store anime
out Broadcom including this s kannur
praise the Sun shirt a stellar best
seller and also the S kannur all held
the one shirt s Kannur in the one form
both designs are originals created by
Cuusoo midi exclusively for anime on
Broadcom so what did everybody think
about these latest developments what do
you think about s canora's brave and
noble conduct as he fought the Endora
spawn without sunshine and what do you
think about the fact that he just got
the power of sunshine back from mile how
do you think that s Kannur is going to
influence the battle against the demon
king and what do you think will be the
ultimate fate of esken or let me know
down in the comments I always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more be sure
to leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell you can follow us on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
for all the latest seven deadly sins
news and updates a huge thank you to all
of our anime uproar patrons for
supporting our work I want to give a
special thank you to our pro hero to
your patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh chops is the man nothing but a
fan and Jason Wilson and another huge
thank you to our the one tier patrons
the ones who stand above all other clans
including baby ray
in grata a lola nod of Maddy Mac and
Michael Calderon if you guys feel that
our content provides value for you and
you want to support more be sure to
check out our patreon link in the
description even donating a single
dollar will give you access to our anime
up for patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching I
really appreciate it and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]